all right my interview with the
computer repair shop repairman is coming
up a big text crackdown on conservatives
is showing no signs of slowing for
example
twitter alternate uh alternative which
by the way was up and running and doing
very very well
is in an uphill battle to get back up
and running especially
after a federal judge actually refused
to reinstate
the site after amazon kicked it off
their web hosting service
meanwhile the mob the media continues to
target news outlets they don't
that doesn't align with their far left
radical socialism
their conspiracy theories their hate
trump lies
even suggesting yeah we we can censor
them we can shut them down
it's a dangerous time in this country
take a look
if they continue to engage in lies
something that he is trying to combat
what is your communication strategy will
you
deny those networks any interviews i
mean
what happens if they re revert to form
immediately
well what look what i could say about
our communication strategy is we
we are committed to reaching every
american if
media companies are are willfully lying
or are not carrying forth
straightforward honest information
from the president when we make him
available or from administration
officials when we make them available
then of course that's something that
we're going to think about and we're
going to factor in
there's a broader societal issue that
it's going to take many years
to detox the disinformation the lies
the hate that has been spread a whole
segment of the american population
has been radicalized deep programming
re-education camps this
is chilling for the entire country by
the way
little ironic said on fake news cnn
that lied and lied and lied about russia
russia russia and pretty much everything
else
day in and day out or same with any
other major network claiming to be
concerned about disinformation what has
they decided
the ones that spewed the russia
collusion hoax
the one that went along with the fake
phony hillary bought and paid for
russian disinformation steel dossier
here's reaction fox news contributor dan
bongino
you know and you have a small little
tiny piece of parlor and
i i talk to some of the guys you work
with they're great guys
and now i see they're they're attacking
you every way imaginable
is the fbi now investigating you is on
drudge tonight
yeah i mean sean i mean is this even
america anymore i i don't even like i
said haven't had a guy i talked to you
sometimes kind of offline and stuff but
i haven't had a a sound good night's
sleep in
in probably three weeks now now listen i
know liberals probably
you know because they love to inflict
pain and
uh you know their totalitarian impose
they love to destroy people they
probably enjoy that they're probably
laughing i can imagine right now but i
wake up every morning and
and i don't even look for good news i
just look for less bad news
we had a representative today carolyn
maloney who is the chair of a very
powerful committee
a congressional representative suggests
to the fbi director
that he investigate parlor did you hear
the reasons why
tell me we still live in america after
this one please or a free america
this is the leftist america which they
want to turn into a marxist superstate
but they wanted us investigated because
one of our executives
wives happened to be born outside of the
country
now i know you're waiting for a punch
line no that's it so
let me get this straight i'm not waiting
for a punch line i want to like find a
cry
room and say this can't happen that
actually happened
and by the way her family the
executive's wife's
family happens to be muslim and lives in
a region
outside of russia and is dirt poor i
actually one of my partners sent me a
picture of the outhouse
outside their house so the democrats
slimeball
totalitarian losers and this loser
maloney
decides she wants the fbi to investigate
our company because the executive
married
a woman whose family is really really
poor
and happens to reside in russia she
presents
no evidence whatsoever that
isn't that xenophobic and islamophobic i
thought the left told us that
and their second reason is even more
hilarious
because after they got us the left d
platform from just about
every company in the united states we
had to go to a multinational company
to protect our website from being hacked
so they want the fbi to investigate
and you know what after the fbi's
ridiculous performance
in the spy gate hoax i wouldn't be
surprised if christopher wray himself
is knocking on my door next week i'm not
even joking if him or his agents were
there next week
i wouldn't i'll report it on i would not
be surprised at all i could see them
knocking on the door
hey we heard one of your executives
married a woman born outside of the
united states
okay you have anything else no no that's
all we need you guys are conservatives
we're allowed to investigate you guys
it's pathetic this country's dead
as a doornail and liberals killed it
it's pathetic
if you think you live in a free country
you're probably a liberal
or someone in the media silence shut
down
cancel and harass we'll continue dan and
follow it
i'm sorry sorry this can't happen our
country